Now that we have illustrated hierarchical planning, what does it tell us about
intelligence? Intelligent agents, both cognitive and artificial, constantly
faced with large, complex problems. The problem spaces corresponding to these
problems often have [INAUDIBLE] explosion of states in them. Intelligent agents
address these complex problems by thinking at multiple levels of abstraction. So
that at any one level of abstraction, the problem appears small and
simple. In order to be able to reason at these multiple levels of abstraction,
we need knowledge at multiple levels of abstraction. In this case,
there was knowledge not only at the level of move operations, but
also the level of macro operations, like unstack and
stack ascending. And perhaps even higher level macro operations, like sort.
This goes back to the fundamental notion of knowledge based AI. Intelligent
agents use knowledge in order to be able to tackle hard, complex problems.